Mike Pence vice president Mike Pence is
now in the GOP race he just appeared on
the clay and buck show and they pressed
him on whether or not if he were elected
president he would pardon Donald Trump
should Donald Trump be convicted for
this nonsense that the Democrats are
attacking him on I think it's a matter
of principle if you believe as as both
buck and I do that Donald Trump is being
prosecuted to a large extent for
political based reasons something that
has never happened in the 240 plus year
History of the United States that we are
setting an awful precedent here to me
not answering is a no
well look
number one I don't think you know what
the president's defense is do you
mean what are the facts I mean look we
either believe in our judicial process
in this country or we don't I get why
Mike Pence is answering this way
I get it I think Mike Pence is a very
nice guy but this is a terrible look